[Applause]
[Music]
tonight we're going to talk about
prosecutors you probably know them from
shows like law and order or the good
wife or fancy justice lady who can
really put off pull off a hat
okay i made up that last one or maybe
i'm here from the future to tell you
about your new favorite show starring
amber ruffin in a hat
prosecutors are so important they even
have their own signature sound
[Music]
you know it that's actually the noise
prosecutors make when they orgasm
scientific fact but here's the thing
that is also one of the whitest sounds
of all time because it turns out that as
of 2019 95 percent of prosecutors were
white and man 95 is so white it's like
i'd like to speak to the manager white
95 percent is front row seats at a billy
joel concert white
america's prosecutors are so white they
think el debarge is a giant mexican boat
and the racial disparity exists all over
the country but hey why does it matter
lots of things are super white and don't
really hurt anyone like living in
vermont or saying i'll be there in a
jiffy
how long is a jiffy white people i need
a number
so let's talk about why the race of
prosecutors matters in three parts first
arrests then charges and finally
sentencing we'll start with the rest now
i know what you're thinking aren't cops
the ones in charge of arresting people
well sort of see there's no point in
arresting someone if they're not going
to be charged with a crime and
prosecutors have basically absolute
power in deciding whether a person gets
criminally charged that's right
prosecutors have the ability to ruin
lives in a split second like plane
crashes or the cool ranch doritos locos
taco supreme combo at taco bell
but i'm still eating that mug
and there are times when prosecutors
choose not to press charges when they
clearly should for example police wanted
to arrest the three men who chased and
murdered a mod arbory but the local d.a
jackie johnson wouldn't allow it then
the case was transferred to this
prosecutor who said there were no
grounds for arrest then they gave the
case to a third white prosecutor who
still didn't arrest anybody it wasn't
until cell phone video of the murder was
released that the state appointed this
woman to the job and she finally charged
ahmad arbury's killers basically those
white prosecutors treated actual
murderers the same way you might treat a
dog who pooped on your living room rug
cover it up pretend it never happened
and hope that someone eventually comes
along and cleans it up for you
since then the three killers have been
convicted by two separate juries and as
for whether the prosecutor's office was
actually racist it is worth noting that
the first d.a actually refused to
prosecute the murderers because one of
them had worked with her in the
prosecutor's office that's right the man
who was just convicted of a federal hate
crime worked for decades in the office
of the district attorney so just like in
scream the call was coming from inside
the house
but arrests aren't the only place where
race plays a role because once you're in
custody prosecutors also get to decide
what crimes you're going to be charged
with and that can be biased as well
a harvard study found that da's charged
black suspects with crimes that carry
worse penalties they ask for higher bail
for black defendants they're less likely
to offer black people plea bargains and
they ask judges to sentence black
defendants to longer terms in prison
in every single possible way black
people face worse outcomes than white
people which is the opposite of what
happens during a line dance
i love it
and even if somehow you are fairly
arrested and charged racism can also
play a role in sentencing now i know you
think i'm going to give you a bunch of
stats about how judges and juries give
longer sentences to black people and
that's true but it's not the most
important thing because over 90 percent
of felony convictions are actually the
result of plea deals and the terms of
those deals are offered by you guessed
it the prosecutors
oh good for them they met someone
a recent new york city study showed that
black defendants were more likely than
whites to be offered plea deals that
included jail or prison time and it's
not just true in new york take these two
ohio women who are convicted of
embezzlement carla hopkins and debbie
bosworth now first yes debbie bosworth
sounds exactly like the name i would
make up for that white lady but it's
also her actual name
now carla stole 42 000 while debbie on
the other hand stole almost a quarter of
a million and carla was sentenced to 18
months in prison while debbie was given
just 10 months
just kidding six just kidding zero she
was given zero prison time fear these
are two women in the same county in the
same court system who were sentenced
within one year of one another
i wonder what could have made the
difference
basically
think of making a fair plea deal like
singing along to a jimmy buffett song
anyone can do it but it's gonna go a
whole lot better if you're white
it's not applicable to me and
margaritaville
is that jimmy buffett uh i don't know
that's fair you shouldn't
now
i know i've spent all this time telling
you about problems with white
prosecutors and to be fair we don't know
for sure that black prosecutors would
fix the criminal justice system we only
know that in studies black judges showed
less of a bias against black defendants
that black cops are less likely to use
force and that juries with at least one
black member are less likely to convict
a black suspect
does that mean that black prosecutors
will do a better job dealing with racial
disparities how the hell would i know
because here's the thing there aren't
enough of them to count but we need to
find out because the next time i hear
this
i only want to be thinking about one
thing
sweet
sweet lovemaking
recently marvel comics introduced a new
character named princess matoka now if
that sounds familiar it's because matoka
is the birth name of an indigenous woman
most of us know as pocahontas now i know
what you're thinking what a great
opportunity to show a historic native
woman for the complicated resourceful
brave person that she was well instead
they did this
wow yeah first that's super racist
second it's very confusing to literally
anyone who has seen a woman in her
underwear
now in case you're wondering if this was
drawn by a man let me point out that
there are zero bra straps and she's
wearing gold pasties and yeah she's
holding up a metal orb entirely with the
strength of her breasts
apparently this comic is set in an
alternate universe where native women
exist but gravity does not
now if it's not clear to you why that
character is upsetting people let's take
a minute and decolonize your
understanding
native women have been hyper-sexualized
throughout american history and the
consequences have been devastating
according to the department of justice
native american women are two to three
times more likely than women of any
other race to experience violence
stalking or sexual assault and that is
terrifying the only thing native women
should experience three times more than
other races is compliments about their
incredible community and nation building
skills then
good job good job now instead of
focusing on this offensive depiction of
matuka let's learn about the reality now
many of you are probably familiar with
her mostly from disney's pocahontas a
movie about a native woman who falls in
love with an english guy named john
smith saves his life has a close
personal friendship with a raccoon
of course almost none of that turns out
to be true i mean i'm not ruling out the
raccoon part they're adorable and they
seem like great listeners i don't know
who her friends were but in reality
matoka was around 10 years old when she
met john smith and he was almost 30 so
instead of this it would have looked a
bit more like this
so
unlike the disney movie there was never
any kind of romance between matoka and
john smith because and this is important
ew
also in every portrait of john smith he
has this facial hair and whether it's
the 1600s or 2022 i think we all would
have clocked that mustache as something
you don't let around young children
so
disney was wrong about the romance and
the age although that's definitely not
disney's biggest age-related lie
i'm just gonna say it there's no way
chip is mrs pot's son
here is what she looks like when she
turns back into a human that lady is in
her late 60s easy now you're telling me
she has a kid chips age
what kind of secrets are you hiding in
that teapot mrs potts
the movie also says that matoka snuck
food to john smith and even risked her
own life to stop her tribe from
executing him but it turns out those
parts probably aren't true either first
of all according to the indigenous site
indian country today when the colonists
didn't grow enough food for themselves
john smith actually stole food from the
tribe by holding a gun to the heads of
village leaders so natives like matoka
likely gave john smith food in the same
way that cashier gives all his money to
a gyneski mask
and as for matoka saving john smith from
execution well historians say that
probably didn't happen either in fact
many deny that he was going to be
executed at all
that's right native historians have
called out the lies just like i'm going
to call out anyone who thinks john smith
is hotter than coco
you are wrong and i will fight you
you're you're wrong and i'm gonna fight
you john smith looks like if ex body
spray was a person
he's the human embodiment of crushing a
beer can on your forehead
he's the third to last guy on every
season of the bachelorette and you know
what else john smith's bangs are the
mcdonald's logo
there
that's right i said it so why is it that
many of us have learned this incorrect
history well because america likes
stories about native women that make it
look like they welcome western culture
and live happily ever after the actual
story of matuka is a devastating one
according to native accounts she was
kidnapped raped by colonists and died
before the age of 21. and no matter how
many adorable raccoons you add that
story sucks but it's the truth so for
just a second let's bring back this
picture now the writer actually
apologized for his depiction of princess
matuka and vowed to change the name and
the design after he was called out on
twitter by native comic lovers but i
don't want to focus on the writer of
that comic i do want to talk about why
it matters because continuing to
hyper-sexualize indigenous women in
fiction can lead us to ignore their
abuse in real life according to a 2016
report from the national institute of
justice more than four out of five
indigenous women reported they had been
the victim of violence and 96 percent of
them described their attacker as
non-native american
even worse those attackers often can't
be prosecuted that's because a 1978
supreme court case called olefant versus
indian tribe decided tribes have limited
authority to prosecute non-tribal
citizens that leaves open
a legal loophole where in some cases
non-natives can enter a reservation
commit violence and not be held
responsible which is insane it's like if
i went to florida and kicked a bunch of
people in the shins and then i got away
with it because i don't live in florida
that's not right i should be held
accountable or i'll just keep kicking
poor tarik now here's the thing we as
artists and consumers have to be extra
careful in how we treat native people
because our country has not been
theorefen show is filmed on the
traditional land of the lenape people's
past and present and we honor with
gratitude the land itself and the people
who have stewarded it throughout the
generations it is our duty
it's our duty to make sure indigenous
women are depicted with care and
integrity and more importantly make sure
they get a chance to depict themselves
that means supporting native women in
everything from writer's rooms to
boardrooms it means donating to the
national indigenous women's resource
center it means supporting positive
native representation by watching shows
like reservation dogs and rutherford
falls
and speaking of support it also means
making damn sure they get all the bra
straps they need this has been how do we
get here tonight we're gonna talk about
medicine and just a little tip laughter
is not the best one if you don't believe
me find someone with a peanut allergy
give them a reese's cup and then tell
them a knock knock joke
knock knock they're dead now
specifically we're going to talk about a
practice in medicine called race
correction that's when medical
calculations are adjusted based on a
patient's race and race correction can
result in disastrous outcomes for people
of color now these adjustments affect
just about every part of the body but
since we're still in a giant respiratory
pandemic let's start by talking about
the lungs i think of them as the tia and
tamara of the human body because there
are two of them and they are very close
to my heart
for more than a century doctors have
assumed that black people have a smaller
lung capacity than white people why well
to understand we're going to have to go
all the way back to 1851 to meet a man
named samuel cartwright now i'm going to
warn you
you're going to be really mad at this
guy but you can never hate him as much
as his own barber obviously did
now cartwright was a white doctor who
decided he was going to investigate
quote the diseases and physical
peculiarities of the negro race which is
already a red flag right there
it's like when you go on a first date
and the guy tells you all his exes are
crazy chad
the only thing all those girls have in
common is you
now lo and behold dr cartwright
discovered a bunch of what he called
negro diseases for example he insisted
he found one called drapedomania that
was rampant in the black population he
said that this horrifying disease and i
swear i'm not making it up induces the
negro to run away from service that's
right this white man thought that
enslaved people were running away
because of a medical disease and not and
i'm just spitballing here because
they're enslaved
that's basically like saying i've
discovered a disease that makes a
waitress spit in my food every time i
grab her ass i call it diner mania
also
cartwright discovered another disease
that i'm not even going to try to
pronounce because he made it up so why
should i bother
cartwright claimed that this disease
made enslaved people
lazy
that's right the enslaved people were
lazy not the white people enjoying a
mint julep while they did all the work
and the main symptom of this disease
lesions on the enslaved people's backs
now i wonder how they got there and this
will probably come as no surprise
cartwright said the best treatment for
his made-up disease was more
whipping
that's the worst medical prescription
since well laughter so what does all of
this have to do with the lung capacity
we were talking about earlier okay well
on top of everything else cartwright was
also the first doctor to measure
um lung capacity between black and white
people he called something he used
something called a spirometer which
looks like a very scientific bond
and he concluded that black people have
a lower lung capacity than white people
now my instinct would be not to believe
anything this reverse eddie munster said
but the medical profession went a
different way because to this day
spirometers use a race-based correction
that assumes that a
10 to 15 percent smaller lung capacity
for black patients but the actual
science on that is very unclear race is
connected to things like access to
health care or likelihood of living in
polluted areas things that people of
color are more likely to experience so
while there's no evidence that race
determines lung health there is plenty
of evidence that racism could and those
are the kinds of things an algorithm
does not pick up besides anyone who
wants to say that black people have weak
lungs should be required to listen to
whitney houston do this
[Applause]
she tricked us into loving america yeah
that woman has the lung capacity of 1
000 women and one hot air balloon now
why does all this talk of lung capacity
matter well because if you think someone
has diminished lung capacity then you're
not as worried when they get a
respiratory infection and their numbers
are lower you might take longer to get
the medical care which could lead to
more serious illness and all those small
decisions add up for example according
to the cdc black people are currently
hospitalized for covid at a rate two and
a half times that of white people so the
numbers matter and it's not just the
lungs that are affected by these
algorithms because the racism creeps
through all the rest of the body as well
for example black women have the highest
rates of c-section at least partially
because of something called a v-back
score the v-back score is an algorithm
that estimates the chance a woman has of
a successful vaginal birth after she's
had a c-section think of it like an
s-a-t for your vag
the v-back score is important because
c-sections are much riskier than vaginal
births and up until just a couple months
ago the vbac actually automatically said
that black and latinx women had a higher
risk score than white women that means
more women of color were advised to get
a c-section which can be dangerous but
recently researchers looked into why
that was included in the algorithm at
all and like marjorie taylor green says
to herself every morning when she looks
in the mirror get ready for some racism
because
they realize the algorithm was based on
an old study that found that being
unmarried and not having insurance
actually increased the risk it wasn't
race at all but someone saw a single
parent and lack of health care access
and program that into their little
algorithm as black and latinx which is
so devastatingly racist i'd like to find
whoever wrote it and give them this
haircut
but
guess what it gets worse because the
american heart association has something
called a heart failure risk score that's
the score doctors use to predict the
risk of death in patients who have been
admitted to the hospital the higher the
score the greater your risk it's a
single number that can change your life
think of it like the powerball except
the prize is getting admitted to the
hospital
according to the new england journal of
medicine the heart failure risk score
automatically assigns three additional
points to any patient identified as
non-black
so basically think of those points like
jokes on an episode of prairie home
companion you're gonna get a whole lot
more of them if you're white
now what this means for parents is that
the algorithm automatically categorizes
all black patients as lower risk whether
they are or not and that has dangerous
results a 2019 study found that black
and latinx patients with heart failure
were less likely than white patients to
be admitted to the cardiology service
that's heartbreaking literally and the
list goes on a race-adjusted algorithm
makes black americans kidney function
look better even though they have higher
rates of end-stage kidney disease a
different algorithm used by hospitals to
decide which patients get follow-up care
let healthier white patients into the
programs ahead of black patients who
were sicker
and the examples are endless but my
point is hospitals treat people not
numbers patients of color deserve to go
to the doctor and receive health care
without bias and for doctors to take
into account their individual
circumstances instead of their race
but until then every single person who
makes one of these racist algorithms
should have to get the cart right this
has been how did we get here first let's
get one thing straight katanji brown
jackson is qualified to be on the
supreme court she went to harvard law
school she was a public defender and a
supreme court clerk and a district judge
and a court of appeals judge and she
played ranette in her college production
of the musical little shop of floors
and
last i checked that is exactly what the
constitution requires but throughout the
hearings there has been one phrase that
just keeps showing up
what do you say to people say you're
soft on crime the allegation that judge
jackson is soft on crime we see
that she has this tendency to be soft on
crime
is it even possible for a black woman to
be soft on crime the black women i know
give the harshest possible sentences for
crimes like hooting and hollering or
running in and out that door
let's talk about where the idea of soft
on crime came from and why it matters
when it's used to tear down a black
judge to figure that out let's go back
to the 1960s you know when you could
smoke on airplanes and also in the nicu
the 60s were an interesting time in
southern politics let's see if you
noticed something here's the electoral
map of the deep south in 1956. here it
is again in 1960 and now here's 1964.
now normally when something turns red
that fast it's because it got stung by a
bee so what happened well in 1961
republicans created something called the
southern strategy the southern strategy
sounds like a plan to drive across
mississippi without getting pulled over
if you're a black it's not going to work
but
in reality the southern strategy was a
plan crafted by the republican party so
that they could win the south by getting
all the racists to vote for them which
is crazy obviously they can't just put
racist in charge of a party and say we
support jim crow now oh wait my bad
that's exactly what they did
in 1964 the republican party gave their
presidential nomination to barry
goldwater a senator who publicly fought
against the civil rights act outlawing
segregation he also ruined the name
barry for the next 50 years and then
this guy made it cool again
republicans also begged strom thurmond
to join their party and bringing in
strom thurman to make your political
party more racist is like bringing in
live grizzly bears to make your dinner
party more exciting
the problem is that it works too well so
here's two facts about strom thurman one
he hated black people so much he once
gave a 24-hour long speech to stop them
from getting civil rights and two he had
a black daughter with his father's 16
year old maid and publicly denied her
existence for over 70 years
honestly i'd rather hang out with the
bears now
why are we rehashing all of this now
well it's because that so-called
southern strategy echoes to this day
during the 1964 campaign goldwater's
vice presidential candidate william e
miller gave a speech warning americans
about ruthless mobs those mobs were
actually black protesters and he used a
new phrase to describe people who
supported them soft on crime even though
the protesters were not criminals this
was the beginning of decades of
republicans using soft on crime as a
euphemism for democrats are going to let
violent negroes come get you you know
like how sorry i missed your texas
euphemism for i definitely saw your text
but did not feel like answering it
and
since then republicans have used soft on
crime as a euphemism for all kinds of
racist stuff richard nixon talked about
a war on crime while internal memos said
that their campaign plan was to pit the
races against each other ronald reagan
worked so hard to prove he wasn't soft
on crime that by the time he left office
the prison population had doubled and
george h.w bush was so desperate to show
america he hated crime that he did one
of the weirdest things i have ever seen
this
this is crack cocaine
seized a few days ago by drug
enforcement agents
in a park just across the street from
the white house
it could easily have been heroin or pcp
it's as innocent looking as
candy [ __ ] what candy are you eating
that looks like a bag of mozzarella
cheese
i'm not sure what's worse the fact that
this man brought crack into the white
house or the fact that that's not the
craziest thing i've seen a u.s president
do
that's his hand and that's his daughter
but here's the thing the reason
republicans accuse their opponents of
being soft on crime is because it works
it's a coded way for republicans to tell
voters my opponent will not keep black
people under control in fact the
southern strategy worked so well that it
won republicans the deep south and to
this day democrats have never regained
control so all that brings us back to
judge jackson when jackson is accused of
being soft on crime she gets all the
implications that come with it and to
show just how ridiculous those
accusations can be here's senator come
tom cotton asking the world's dumbest
question do you think we should catch
this is imprison more murderers or fewer
murderers
i don't know tom this seems like
something you would figure out without
the help of a future supreme court
justice also why do you look like an
adult version of doug
but
why did he really ask that question it's
because he wants to associate this black
woman with crime he's using her in the
same way his predecessors have for the
past 50 years judge katanji brown has
been endorsed by the international
association of the chiefs of police the
fraternal order of police and 83
democratic and republican former
attorneys general her brother and two of
her uncles served as police officers and
fun fact the supreme court has
absolutely nothing to do with punishing
criminal behavior
sure caller soft on crime but we know
about the southern strategy and we know
what you're really saying it's just like
a text message that says sorry i missed
your text we're not fooled this has been
how did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you